[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos a en primera plana un
programa de radio france internacional y
de france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco
en el fin de una era la era merkel la
canciller alemana que vive sus últimos
momentos en el poder tras un longevo
mandato nos acompañan dos colegas que
conocen bien la política alemana porque
fueron corresponsales allí beatriz juez
corresponsal del correo a que en francia
bienvenida a beatriz
eusebio vall corresponsal de la
vanguardia bienvenido que todo gracias y
allí en berlín nuestro corresponsal de
ref y sergio correa sergio buenos días
cuando había carlos y bueno en
bienvenidos desde acá desde berlín
esperando claro las vísperas de las
próximas elecciones nacionales y la
despedida de la canciller merkel que
vive todavía en este edificio que está
atrás mío pero que probablemente está
empacando estas cosas
el fin de la era merkel hoy en primera
plana
la líder más solvente y longeva del
siglo 21 la era merkel llega a su fin la
canciller vive sus últimos meses en el
poder tras 16 años en el cargo o lo que
es lo mismo cuatro mandatos consecutivos
algo extraordinario para cualquier líder
y más en los tiempos que corren
merkel ha ejercido ese liderazgo sin
haberse dejado deslumbrar por el poder
son muchos los líderes mundiales que han
tratado de desentrañar en cierta forma
el pensamiento de esta política que
conjuga formación científica capacidad
de análisis de escucha orígenes en la
alemania del este y una fuerza
psicológica impresionante el fin de su
mandato es también el inicio del juicio
histórico a su figura como suele pasar
con los grandes personajes de la
historia y ahora tenemos pocas dudas de
que estamos ante una de ellos repasemos
las portadas que nos deja la figura de
merkel o que nos han dejado en los
últimos tiempos como esta portada de la
revista 'time' que la designó
personalidad del año en 2015 llamado
llamando a merkel canciller del mundo
libre le para a quien francia llama
merkel la jefa la patrona que puede
salvar a europa de esta crisis sanitaria
gracias al 'new deal' entre parís y
berlín
alemán tageszeitung representaba así de
penitente a merkel bajo el título
haciendo un juego de palabras merkel
culpa por el ejercicio de disculpas que
hizo la canciller hace unas semanas
cuando echó marcha atrás las medidas
anti kobe en semana santa un ejercicio
de disculpas que también suele ser
bastante raro en la política actual
bueno ve a fin de una era fin de la era
merkel sólo la atalaya del tiempo nos
ayudará un poco a colocar quizá el
personaje históricamente pero haciendo
un poco de ejercicio como designará en
los libros de historia a merkel pues yo
creo que eso va a ser una de las grandes
políticas de este siglo 21 en europa
esa es una política que ha marcado estos
últimos 16 años y todo lo que ha pasado
en europa
se ha hecho con ella no el eje
franco-alemán siempre es muy importante
pero yo creo que ya como ha coincidido
con tantos políticos han pasado más han
pasado de largo tantos ella siempre
estaba ahí es todo un referente en
algunos lo ven como un ancla para europa
como que siempre estaba ahí que era la
que y otros pues también así como la de
las grandes líderes de esta época
eusebio que dieran los libros de
historia cuando veamos angela merkel dos
puntos
yo creo que dirán que ha sido una una
líder eficaz una líder una líder que ha
ejercido el poder con modestia sin
excesivos show o sin sin nada de show lo
cual es una rareza en estos tiempos
y una político que ha encarnado este
sistema de consenso tan alemán vigente
después de la segunda guerra mundial y
yo destacaría una cosa que quizás habrá
tiempo para hablar no es la la líder
conservadora entre comillas que hecho el
gesto más progresista de las últimas
décadas en europa que fue la acogida de
un millón de inmigrantes de refugiados
de la guerra de siria y para mí eso fue
una decisión muy valiente que de que era
que pagó un precio político pero que con
el paso del tiempo se va a recordar
vamonos hasta berlín con nuestro
corresponsal sergio correa sergio con
qué sensaciones vive el pueblo alemán a
esta recta final de la cancillerãa y
ambiente de fin de una era sí sí hay una
especie de día de hoy orfandad son 16
años no son cuatro periodos
presidenciales es la canciller que ha
estado
en los tiempos modernos es la mujer que
ha estado cada día en la televisión en
alemania en el resto de europa que
algunos niños no conocen otra cantidad
que se halla pero también ha sido cierto
cansancio hay que decirlo hace a la
canción es muy popular pero ya se
escuchó dos tercios de la población
según la última encuesta creen que es
demasiado tener una especie de período
abierto de cancillería en principio
constitucionalmente uno puede ser
reelecto toda la vida pero todo le
parece un poco ridículo espérate estar
protestando contra otros países que
quieren nuestro elegirse tres veces y el
canciller alemán puede estar toda la
vida si quiere entonces es la idea ahora
de dos tercera población alemana es que
se limiten un periodo de canciller a dos
máximos para evitar el congestionamiento
de poder que siempre aceptan mal a las
democracias qué cualidades han permitido
a merkel ser rara avis tan longeva en la
política actual qué cualidades le han
permitido tanto tiempo yo creo que es
una líder bueno como eusebio sosegada
pragmática
sabe escuchar a los demás y no tiene la
decisión tomada de antemano sino que
escucho a los demás y al final en el
último minuto toma la decisión que
considera más más conveniente imagino
que es como dice ser como dice eusebio
porque en alemania existe el sistema
federal y tienen que ponerse de acuerdo
entre ellos y creo que es unas
cualidades que luego también se trabajan
mucho los temas que se estudia todo muy
bien antes de edición por ejemplo para
antes de ir a un consejo europeo pues
tiene todos los temas muy estudiados se
va hablar con unos con los otros e
intenta encontrar un consenso entre
ellos creo que es muy importante porque
estoy en política no siempre será
hablaba antes eusebio de una líder
conservadora entre comillas que toma una
decisión más vinculada al campo
progresista como se suele como se suele
hablar de la acogida de refugiados y por
eso le devuelvo la pregunta eusebio
donde situamos entonces ideológicamente
angela merkel en donde podríamos situar
la
pues yo la situaría en el centro y una
política como he dicho eficaz y
pragmática es decir yo era corresponsal
en italia cuando la crisis de los
inmigrantes que había días que llegaban
7000 8000 era un drama humano terrible y
bueno aquí en francia había un gobierno
socialista encabezado por presidido por
françois hollande y no movió un dedo o
mejor dicho novo no movió un barco para
ir a rescatar a esta gente no había ongs
francesas pero no había ningún barco
francés en cambio si españoles incluso
noruegos y la que realmente marcó marcó
la historia fue angela merkel yo yo creo
que este debate izquierda-derecha se
está difuminando y teníamos que hablar
más de populismos radicalismos o
pragmatismo si ella es una líder
centrista y pragmática
y no solo de retórica sino que va a
demostrarlo y quizá precisamente así ha
simbolizado en la cara antagónica al
populismo un mundo en donde los
populismos han estado en auge la otra
cara esa cara que identificamos como no
populista era la de merkel
en concreto y una de las cosas que más
me gusta de merkel es que no ha cambiado
cuando yo estaba en alemania cuando
cuando la eligieron canciller yo creo
que es la misma persona que antes usará
el poder no la ha cambiado no es la
misma persona que antes y esto es
también importante y eso me pasa poco a
poco sí por eso por eso me gusta porque
ella es como la misma la misma canciller
en ahora con más experiencia claro
después de 16 años pero que el poder no
la ha cambiado creo que es un rasgo
importante de ella y paralelamente a la
historia de merkel la historia de europa
bueno que ha vivido en numerosas crisis
durante estos años de merkel la crisis
de la deuda la crisis de los refugiados
el ver exit ahora la crisis sanitaria en
ocasiones de hecho se ha acusado a
merkel
crear una unión europea' a su imagen y
semejanza y en otras más bien se
agradecido que existiese al menos una
líder solvente en el bloque que nos
salvará de males mayores la historia
daba a juzgar como un europeísta yo creo
que sí porque en fin cuando hubo la gran
crisis financiera del 2007 2008 aunque
con dificultades se logró parar el golpe
ayudar a grecia no siempre es fácil en
en alemania este tipo de políticas había
mucha presión interna y ahora hemos
visto la gran decisión histórica de
poner en común la deuda de europa que
eso era un anatema en alemania es decir
que toda la unión europea pudiera
endeudarse como bloque era algo en mis
tiempos en alemania absolutamente
impensable y ella terminó aceptándolo
otra muestra de pragmatismo algunos
quizás la pueden acusar de no haber sido
suficientemente visionaria
pero yo creo que europa ha tenido suerte
estos años de que como ha dicho beatriz
de que merkel estuviera ahí en la
cancillería de mejor no es lo que nos
sobran son líderes visionarios no hay
demasiado visionario en el mundo
nada ver alguna frase que dijo merkel
hace tiempo que me parece interesante
sobre esto es que alemania solo le era
bien si a europa le va bien que resuma
un poco su pensamiento sabe que si no se
que si grecia sale del euro nos llevó
hay una crisis gigante en algunos de los
países y es consciente de que eso afecta
también a alemania y en las empresas
alemanas a todos pero en eso perdón ha
habido ya una continuidad de helmut kohl
que fue su gran padre político que
también aplicó la misma política
recordemos las ayudas inmensas que los
fondos de cohesión o no para españa es
decir que que es una línea de
continuidad cambiado en la política
alemana que ya no es solo merkel sino
que viene de muchos años antes
ese es el pasado miremos al futuro en
septiembre hay elecciones en alemania
armin la 7 es el candidato
por la cdu el partido democristiano y a
sustituir a la canciller tras un proceso
muy largo en el que ha habido y sigue
habiendo muchas dudas
sergio tanto pese al temor al gran
espacio vacío que dejará canciller
muchísimo claro canciller ha dominado
todo este periodo no ha dejado a nadie
mucho acerca del poder de hecho le puede
contar una anécdota cuando llegó al
poder y le pregunté un político de
segunda fila del partido demócrata
cristiano como esa mujer que parecía tan
débil se podía defender contra estos
tiburones y me dijo si arreglás si tiras
al mar que él dentro de una piscina
llena de pirañas no va a quedar una sola
piraña eso se mezcla tiene ansiedad que
tiene ella para estar en el poder
trató de poner a dos candidatas mujeres
de su partido para su confianza para que
la sucederá ninguno de los dos salió
finalmente del niño siendo la chet el
elegido una en calidad poder no muy
querido por nadie ni por la gente ni por
el partido que está allá con periodos de
apoyo muy bajos
estima del 20 por ciento de gente que
quiere solamente votar a la cdu en
contra el 30 y algo que hubo las
elecciones pasadas o sea que la ira de
merkel también produce una caída en todo
el partido
bueno qué va a suceder
angela merkel una historia de hace
muchos años era el año 88 éramos jóvenes
teníamos 26 27 años hicimos un viaje
juntos en un grupito de 10 corresponde a
10 periodistas y otra banda ya en la
vanguardia por cinco países de
centroamérica y como yo era el único del
grupo que hablaba alemán congeniamos y
pasamos 15 días juntos no ha pasado
muchos años pero puedo decir que ya lo
viento todavía estaba el muro porque
todavía estaba el muro pero yo lo
recuerdo como un joven conservador pero
muy pero moderado y pragmático
pragmático nada rígido
un día que no quisimos seguir el
programa oficial que nos habían
propuesto y nos fuimos los dos a la
playa que un alemán de aquellos
estereotipos típico alemán no no
rompería el programa por esto no muchos
años pero eres un perfil un poco de la
persona que va a suceder previsiblemente
angela merkel vamos a hacer una breve
pausa
instantes continuamos analizando la
figura de merkel aquí en primera plana
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
sus historias inspiran el futuro su día
a día es la actualidad su cultura sus
luchas sus éxitos y están en el corazón
de nuestros programas
descontamos los que hicieron a américa
latina y los que la construyen hoy les
contamos un mundo hecho día a día por
los que lo habitan
liberté égalité continuamos en primera
plana esta semana analizando la figura
de angela merkel en sus últimos meses
que le quedan en el poder analizando
este longevo mandato de 16 años y toda
la figura de angela merkel lo hacemos
con beatriz juez corresponsal del diario
'el correo' que lo fue en alemania
también lo fue en alemania eusebio va el
corresponsal de la vanguardia y en
dúplex desde berlín nuestro corresponsal
sergio correa les quiero formular una
pregunta que a mí particularmente me
interesa mucho durante mucho tiempo se
ha hablado de el método merkel de para
llegar a negociaciones para ejercer el
poder en que cree en qué consiste ese
llamado método merkel bueno como
hacíamos antes siempre busca el consenso
se escucha a los demás y luego toma una
decisión que considera que es más
adecuada no y ya parte también de su
formación científica y de su formación
la temática está ahí a la hora de
negociar a la hora de ver bien si yo
creo que no solventar conflictos también
si ella se estudia todos los temas mucho
sabe conoce por qué pie cojea cada uno e
intenta encontrar consensos y quiero que
sí que sí
él se vio que su formación científica le
ha ayudado recuerdo una rueda de prensa
en plena pandemia donde ella empezó a
hacer números que es algo bastante
insólito para un líder no de hecho la
mayoría de líderes son abogados han
estudiado derecho han estudiado ciencias
políticas ella es una física y yo creo
que eso tiene su importancia en la
manera en que analiza los problemas
[Música]
y totalmente de la demagogia y de la
demagogia lo cual es algo que cada vez
sucede menos creen que es una líder con
convicciones porque durante todos estos
años en el poder hemos visto como merkel
en coaliciones sucesivas iba adoptando
políticas que en teoría no formaban
parte de su campo a priori conservador
el matrimonio igualitario el salario
mínimo en alemania la acogida de
refugiados hemos visto muchas políticas
que no la pertenecían a merkel pero que
merkel ha llegado a adoptar y yo creo
que tiene una línea roja que es no
pactar con la extrema derecha y luego el
otro pues se va adaptando considerando
porque es lo mejor porque muchos también
cuando ha gobernado con gran coalición
con los socialdemócratas pues tiene que
encontrar consensos no para no romper la
coalición entonces yo creo que es eso
que es lo que es importante para ella
volvemos en este punto a berlín porque
la biografía de merkel sergio es la de
una joven alemana del este quien logró
prevalecer en solitario sobre hombres
del oeste alemán y los fue ganando uno a
uno hija de un pastor luterano doctora
en física y sin duda un animal político
una biografía que sorprende por todos
los moldes que ha roto se reconoce
también así en alemania ciertamente
porque angela merkel es la primera mujer
que ha llegado tan lejos y es una mujer
del este y se relee extrema alemana 30
años después de la reunificación sigue
siendo una marca haber nacido y crecido
en la alemania oriental en la llamada
alemania comunista hace que la gente
tenga bastante más difícil para llegar a
cargos altos yo ya lo consiguió y además
lo consiguió siendo protestante hija un
pastor protestante como bien dijiste que
consiguió gobernado entre un partido
católico es algo seguramente un poco más
pragmático de lo que se dice el nombre
de partido democratacristiano ahora
puede
en tantos años una protestante pero creo
que ha sido una biografía muy muy muy
muy especial a ustedes han sorprendido
algunos datos de la biografía de merkel
algo que quieran poner de bueno ya
cuando cayó el muro no fue a ver cómo
[Música]
trabajar con él qué tipo de ideología
tiene claro haber crecido en el este y
ya está vacunada controlar contra
ciertas propagandas de la izquierda y de
ella está pero tampoco es po decir que
fue una conservadora típica no es decir
no lo pensemos el año 89 90 una persona
del este se sentía atraída por por la
cdu porque occidente era la gran
esperanza es que claro las jóvenes
generaciones quizás no tengan tan claro
pero irá a berlín en él
86 87 y pasará al muro y ver los dos
modelos no había color a no ser que
tuvieras unas ojeras ideológicas
la sensación que ya desprende es que
podía haber sido perfectamente la
canciller del spd de los socialistas
alemanes y estaríamos hablando
exactamente casi de lo mismo yo estaba
estado gobernando muchos años claro se
te deje sin zinc sin demasiados
problemas sin demasiados problemas
sergio qué aspectos del albacete algo
más
santiago qué aspecto de la vida y de la
forma de hacer política de la canciller
quedarán grabados en la historia hay
consenso general sobre este aspecto de
dignidad algo tan inusual en la política
actual sí bueno hay una crítica
características muy especiales de ella
lo primero de todo es cierta capacidad
de consenso es algo casi inédito es
algunos dicen que es un poco abusivo en
el sentido en que ella ha tomado de los
demás partidos de los socialdemócratas y
de los verdes
sus reivindicaciones propias los han
incorporado dentro del partido demócrata
cristiano y ha movido a su partido más
hacia la centroizquierda casi se podría
decir una oposición que no estaba
con una
el partido socialdemócrata digamos pero
también ha traído una consecuencia
secundaria bastante nefasta que es que a
la gente más conservador entre los
partidos han ido a la parte del partido
de extrema derecha de la este de la
alianza por alemania pero en todo caso
esta mujer ha conseguido el consenso y
ha puesto algo muy importante entre la
política que todos los préstamos
bastante contentos y claro que todo el
mundo está cansado de ese estilo
agresivo de ese estilo confrontativo
acusativo incluso de inmigrante que se
ha acostumbrado en la política
occidental de las últimas décadas diría
yo eso merkel lo ha evitado
completamente que ha producido un efecto
muy saludable no puede ir a un congreso
a una reunión del congreso y hay
confrontación pero nunca hay difamación
nunca hay gritos y eso se lo debemos a
angela merkel
fíjate lo está comentando sergio esas
grandes coaliciones que he tenido ser y
que ha tenido angela merkel adoptando
políticas del spd y como finalmente
angela merkel lograba ganar o fagocitar
al spd no salían perdiendo
también había críticas por el lado del
spd de hacer pactos con ella no por ese
por ese tema así pues como siempre no si
haces un pacto con alguien y tienes que
ceder luego pues esa persona también
saca provecho entonces en este caso como
no hay tampoco un líder que pueda
sustituir a merkel buenas ahora puede
hacer competencia pues ha sido de ella
ella ha sacado provecho de todos lados
no como ningún líder que le pueda hacer
en la política actual hay alguien que
podamos decir que se parece o que
recuerda a angela merkel o que pueden en
la escena internacional que podamos
decir o no
es difícil el caso de draghi en italia
quizás se acerca un poco pero vamos a
ver lo que dura dry y teniendo en cuenta
la política italiana lo que es el
gobierno que tiene como líder europeo
está claro que sería emanuel macro
que está por ver si logra ser reelegido
es otro perfil no es un perfil sin duda
tan tranquilo y humilde y en el propio
país tiene una contestación fuerte pero
ya mi nombre se me ocurre en este
momento nadie más que no sea macro si
gana y por qué si gana por poco su
autoridad quedará mermada aquí en
francia y como consecuencia también en
europa
hay alguien que te pueda recordar no yo
creo que merkel es es única es como dice
él siempre el eje el eje franco-alemán
siempre es importante y la figura de
macrón es importante pero sus estilos no
tienen nada que ver
mckeon es super arrogante
y comparado con merkel que es bastante
modestas yo creo que no tiene
comparación pero fijaos igual que de
otros grandes líderes hemos hablado de
movimientos políticos que van asociados
hablamos del tram mismo hablamos del
sarkozysmo aquí en francia e incluso en
españa hablamos del santísmo con pedro
sánchez lo curioso es que angela merkel
después de 16 años no hablamos del
merkel ismo es decir hay algo como que
no está vinculado en ella hacia un
movimiento de impregnar un todo sino que
bueno es ella es los acuerdos a los que
ha llegado pero sorprende que no exista
creo que es bueno es saludable es
saludable es saludable y ese espíritu
que yo creo que va más allá de merkel
porque si repasamos los 16 länder
alemanes vemos que hay coaliciones de
todos signos coalición
grandes coaliciones de los dos grandes
partidos coaliciones de izquierda de
verdes con democristianos de verdes con
socialdemócratas es decir es un estilo
de gobierno es un de pactos de
pragmatismo
los alemanes tienen la suerte de que no
se circunscriben no se limita a ver que
el que va mucho más allá es una lección
para nuestro europa no digo que no haya
problemas y haya tensiones pero es un
modelo de gobernanza
que es bastante ejemplar antes comentaba
a esos episodios de las grandes crisis
europeas que ha tenido que afrontar
angela merkel la crisis de la deuda la
crisis de los refugiados el ver exit la
crisis de la cob y sobre todo esas
cuatro y cuál creen que es la que más ha
marcado a la canciller en la que más
implicado la que más le ha quitado el
sueño de los inmigrantes ha sido la de
los refugiados yo creo que ha sido un
poco la la que nos sorprendió un poco a
todos y bueno y esta última también lo
de la deuda por el gobierno yo creo que
esas dos son las crisis que han marcado
de hecho ella tiene claro que esta
crisis sanitaria que es su última etapa
en el poder es sistémica y que es
importante que europa la resuelva la
resuelva y que estos meses en lo que le
queda en el poder está destinado a ello
lo tiene y lo tiene claro no si yo
también que es muy importante eso
también la la postura que ha tenido
respecto a trump respecto putin same si
no no ha sido fácil no ha sido fácil
para él sido fácil lidiar con con rusia
hay muchos intereses económicos en juego
y el famoso
producto y todo lo ha llevado de un modo
bastante hábil siendo dura en ocasiones
pero sin tensar la cuerda hasta el
límite para que se rompa es decir en ese
terreno no solamente euro sino relación
con rusia relación con trump ha sabido
ser pragmática en un mundo con demasiada
de estos defender defender los intereses
alemanes europeos pero preservar algunas
grandes líneas preservan alianzas y no
poner al mundo en una situación de
peligro el hecho de haber vivido en
alemania del este pues la ayudado un
poco a comprender la mentalidad rusa por
eso no era mejor otro político que
hubiese crecido en alemania occidental
se comprendía misma conexión que putin
empezó a tenerla bastante respeto cuando
empezó a hablar en ruso en esas primeras
encuentros entre ambos muchísimas
gracias
eusebio beatriz ha sido un placer trazar
también a ti sergio desde berlín este
este perfil es de angela merkel
vive ya sus últimos sus últimos meses en
el poder muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes le esperamos aquí la próxima
semana en primera plana